typically the way the black cats are
portrayed in witchcraft stories is that
they're the familiar familiar spirits so
what is the familiar Spirit a familiar
spirit is basically a demon that is
assigned to a family for Generations so
it can come for like four or five
generations so it's a it's a it's a it's
a spirit that at the time especially
like if you come from generations of
Witchcraft it's a spirit that it will it
comes to you because of your ancestors
so it's someone that helps you to do the
I'm saying this but it's not like that
they are demons they um they help you
with the rituals with the potions they
kind of also act as guide and also as
protectors so when I did a ritual before
my dad died I was consecrated to this
spirit guide so he became my my spirit
guide but they can take the form of
animals that's why the blood cats